courageux
super
français
alix mareux moi je suis le président de
la pauvreté à l'association
non
on
professionnellement j'ai town et les
assurances je suis parti ça fait le 1er
octobre
déjà ça fait onze ans que tu as un
retrait ouais
je suis parti dans le cadre de la loom
c'est le vélo qui en a bénéficié
le oui avec le vélo du pays comme en
mêlée
dans la famille mon père en a fait à
l'époque
c'était mignon vix d'accord pignon fixe
et une seule couronne à l'avant pignon
fixe à l'arrière et pas de dérailleur
njawe on n'y a pas du plateau alors
aujourd'hui dans un endroit et
une dizaine de pignons à l'arrière de
mon frère qui est sur le toit d'ailleurs
on a fait aussi et c'est un peu grâce à
lui que j'ai mis les pieds à l'étrier et
ventilés je n'en ai pas fait moi je
m'occupe du des autres c'est très
convivial sa réussite toute la famille
les frères et soeurs pour donner
toujours sur le compte à rebours à
chaque fois bienvenue cautionnement pas
ce que c'était pas comme maintenant
alors c'était le 1er mai votre voile a
été le premier essai près c'était on
attendait ce moment avec impatience
j'aurais plaisir mon petit fils je lui
donne il aime les petites vannes de la
réunion
on va recommencer après me revient et il
reprend définitivement allez bon
dimanche à toi
abella tu vois on est au port l'un c'est
l'étape finale le le circuit la commune
de paris mais là on prend une belle
force pour panthier à sur l'épaule cet
après midi il y aura du soleil
son expérience dans les courses et plus
de démarches administratives
ça c'est un principal choc est content
du choix est grand comme tout le monde
on est là mais il yad'autres notre aide
aux familles qui ont peu près le même
il ya des années de ça mais il ya des
familles qui sont les amis collection
d'art qu'ils sont là et les gens ne
comprennent pas justement ce qui fait
que les gens croient mais il se donne
mais c'est pas facile c'est quand même
quand on prend la responsabilité de
faire quelque chose on me dira donné
deux pilotes de commencement jusqu'à la
fin le gibus est aussi un sport
collectif
parce qu'il faut s'entraider entre
coéquipiers et quand ça va pas chez l'un
il faut absolument essayer de trouver
une solution pour que avec les autres ça
avance mais ça y est c'est la dernière
là on voit le le dispositif de sécurité
dans tron se met en place avec le tour
ils emplissent on à la musique on
s'amuse
oda
c'est très beau c'est formidable parce
que je sais que derrière que quand j'ai
demandé un service
je n'ai pris avant d'occuper
et
du
ça a été un choix difficile dans la
concrétisation ce sera aussi difficile
mais on a fait un choix et aujourd'hui
on annonce que c'est ma dernière
organisation
mon dernier tour oui à ses enfants mais
content mais je pense que là il a il a
signé pour la retraite complète
l'équipe rythme solide beaucoup plus
qu'avant paizinho mais je reviens sur ma
famille m'a permis aux allures ensuite
disponibilité sans difficulté deux
motorisés raconter ce cette
disponibilité poids occupés et vaquer à
cette occupation
on aime comme huit jeunes
hollande comme il était par exemple on
s'entend
longue vie en temps au vélo à la réunion
c'était formidable
mais chez nous un peu bête l'enjoint
bien là ça y est c'est bon
l'avenir est assuré mais la bâtisse du
sud